how's the Gomer as many it's fair to Pat
welcome back to the walking dead I'm not
supposed to be in labor yet Kenny what
if something's wrong nothing's wrong
babies know how to be born zambie baby's
coming Clementine where'd you find the
building around back has an observation
deck somewhere the baby will be safer
it's coming so much faster than I
thought it's high up so it should be
safe from walkers sounds good as soon as
Mike and Bonnie you're back we'll go hey
Clem
she wanted you made it back safe how are
you feeling scared and it hurts
I wish I was here
everything Alvin did was for you and the
baby giving himself up to Carver like
that it was to try to keep you and the
baby safe yeah I know it's a waste of
time but I can't stop thinking about
things I should have said to him things
I should have talked to him about how am
I ever gonna do this without him you're
going to be a good mom
we sure have come a long way since we
first met huh you're a good kid
Clementine I'm glad you'll be there to
watch out for this baby ah oh [ __ ] I got
this we ain't seen Mike Rabbani in a
while and I'm not saying I don't trust
him but I'd appreciate it if you went
and checked up on them yeah go ahead
I'll be fine you guys should walk over
meanwhile I don't know I don't like
where this is all going don't feel very
good about it
let's talk candy really quick I can
what's up are you okay Kenny
sure why wouldn't
all right then
and follow Mike and Bonnie stretch
for a long time
a long long long time oh I forgot Sarah
[ __ ] I didn't see her oh well what are
you gonna do
we don't have time for her anymore right
now
hey Clem I thought you went with Jane
she didn't take off did she yeah she's
trying to get the place we found ready
for Rebecca well that's good yeah give
me like ten more minutes to search
around ten minutes go back empty-handed
what I just want to help I love you guys
don't do nothing cannonball i watch this
side
you watch the other deal I never had an
empty
you think maybe they say that stuff
about water and blankets just to get
people out of the way no you don't know
what the hell you're talking about
and you didn't have to come with me even
I know the blanket warranty never mind
maybe the chicks had put something in
the cannon to hide
where you going climb
Jane said these don't work anymore yeah
good just for she'll be handy they're
also really loud good point
we need to find something right there
sure been some animals through here
watch where you sit
when we got here Civil War code that
couldn't be useful
[Music]
Hey look at this an old coat nice good
fine clam you should hang on to that
it's kind of get a lot colder before it
starts getting warmer Kenny said we need
blankets it's not really a blanket but
but it should do the trick
good call I guess you've already got
that old coat I gave you I feel so bad
about everything that happened hopeful
you won't always think of me like that
not that I blame you if you did I
haven't always used the best judgment
you finally opened your eyes about
Carver and what a bad person he was
that's something yeah
I'm found a jacket that's great but it's
a gray the you know yeah my South we
can't put Rebecca and a Confederate coat
oh I didn't even think about that guess
it's better than nothing though oh I
forgot yeah that's who cares at this
moment come on it's not like she was
there while it happened no not so much
unless you want some pretty good gloves
please Oh
let's get suicide thinking about back
only
I'll tell you I sure don't like being
near a graveyard with the world the way
it is now way things are now you're in a
graveyard all the time yeah true enough
that's it
careful there Kenan
what are we gonna do with that why did
oh really he didn't [ __ ] try that you
see that's some watering they're over
here water bottled and claimed that's
just what we need
it's locked
you want to kick it down mr. Kent
doesn't make an awful lot of noise yeah
maybe you know if somebody was small
enough they could maybe squeeze through
that gap I could try to pry it open some
more but I don't know if that'll help
much we don't have time all right I'll
go thanks Glenn just open the door from
the other side
Michael carry those things out might be
a bit heavy for you
listen hope there's not as a me on the
other side like there are other days I'm
stuck oh maybe I push from surprise
well that happened it always happened
Jesus Mary and Joseph
guessing not quite as small as I used to
be but you're tough for your size [ __ ]
you're top of my size I'm sorry I asked
you I won't do it again
hey [ __ ] enough we need to get out of
here we've got something to bring back
I'll keep checking the other room no
look at this water just carry one each
and get the [ __ ] back thanks Bonnie
Bonnie didn't want to carry that's what
happened that's gotta be heavy is yeah
she can't carry that come on I'll just
let go she can't do it hey I got this
oh damn The Hulk is here holy [ __ ]
that's all right I know it looks like a
lot we could all go through this pretty
quick how about Harville was crazy
Bonnie Hanks won at least his shelves
were always full you're right I thought
it looked like so much that baby's gonna
be hard on everyone especially Rebecca
in between you and me she's not looking
too good hey guys I'm Ivan yeah come on
stick close this episode is [ __ ]
great so far by the way I reckon
McDaniels raccoon
I need this [ __ ] on that raccoon not
like I mean justjust that I'd be really
happy to eat that right now oh my god
with Rebecca shoot don't let it get away
Shh all right we got it corny where is
it mystic here I think it went over the
hair there you've come in your wife
welcome or I can kick him in the face oh
shoot what I took it
no don't the wearables he's like yeah
that's right I'm pregnant hungrier than
I was before
well I'm sort of glad it got away
it had a family yeah me too come on
let's just get this back to her back in
the others yeah we already got a lot
we all have much time to waste how about
Bonnie cares one just that's the whole
crazy idea that I got now telling me
your arms ain't tired
nope I could do this all day [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh God breathe like I told you okay okay
okay baby's coming
[Music]
[ __ ] walkers I think it that close
without anyone seen them yeah yeah we've
got to do something we can't stay here
common time where's the place you went
Jane found I'll show you
good someone help me no oh God
so many we gotta get out of here Mike
get Sarah
[Music]
Sarah get going
like he's okay he's losing it sure I
mean that man is doing to protect us
sure
damn
was about as human as I've felt in a
long time I almost forgot one Clementine
chicky Jesus Clem it's not what's going
on in here
let's get you comfortable what the [ __ ]
are you two doing up here
Kenny what's going on we got God knows
how many walkers out there which you
we're supposed to be keeping an eye out
hey hold off sir just tell me what's
going on what's going on is you're a
reckless [ __ ] more Rebekah's having
the baby now what do you think I'm sorry
Shh right over here they're coming up
the stairs here we should you want to
help get out there and keep the walkers
office I'll do this they can't rush this
on the stairs shoot them before they get
to it
[ __ ] that's a lot we need everyone out
here
help her relax oh [ __ ] calm down
no this baby is coming
oh my god
good clip you need to get out there and
help the others tape shoot it they are
not getting nothing we're gonna run out
of the box
what about this mechanic so why we need
something heavy
the block the gate with this I'll help
him come
together ready
[Applause]
this is so intense [ __ ] oh my oh my god
Oh FAL who fell oh no oh no oh no oh no
no no [ __ ] way I'm doing that I'm
sorry no [ __ ] the way I'm doing that
[Applause]
are you crazy there's no way she's
getting out of that
pull me up sorry we can't leave her
without even trying please
sister wait
that's a good shot honestly you have to
listen to me oh oh she dies anyway she
[ __ ] dies either way oh my god sorry
that's [ __ ] up
we're going down there it wasn't your
fault
you're climbing up what they're gonna
make it up here does this [ __ ] ever end
we need to break the rest of the day
she's right she's right drop the whole
death trap - are you [ __ ] crazy
how are we gonna do the head no smoke
around
ain't gonna work it's too thick
[Music]
she could pry the bolts out that'll work
we bust that the whole thing comes down
boosts me
they're getting closer Clementine I
don't think this is a good idea I don't
think this is a good idea I don't think
this is a good idea what are you guys
gonna do now oh well how convenient
Wow that'd be baby my god baby it's real
oh damn it damn it
SEBI I believe at you
that's adorable hey Clementine hey how's
he doing he's perfect
it was a perfect like me it was the most
perfect little man in the whole world
he looks like Alvin you think so
definitely thank you sorry this Alvin's
baby after all I'm fine I'm fine
I just wish I could get more Clem why
don't you give her that coat we found
sorry you know about the color you
really think I care about that yeah but
I should get that blanket from that
Kenny's jacket could I of course your
family here
[Music]
there you go you a natural look at you
like a big sister here let me take you
man you both should rest
especially you been a long day when's
the last time you slept Kenny how about
two years ago I'm fine plus somebody's
got to watch you while mama gets your
beauty sleep
you never forget that smell
how did she get it open [ __ ] what are
you doing
listen I'm sorry I've got to go I think
it's for the better
I understand good I was worried this was
gonna turn into a thing you know Jamie
Sarah I'm not gonna stick around and
watch it happen to you too
oh wow thanks you know the score
you're a smart kid I'll be okay
sure but give it enough time and
everyone's luck runs out well snuggles
for you to listen when the [ __ ] hits the
fan coz it always does
remember that you can make it on your
own it's not an option for everyone if
things start heading south don't let
them drag you down with them you don't
owe them anything but make you feel like
you do like it's all one happy family
when push comes to shove I owe these
people everything they've kept me safe
looked out for me I wouldn't be here
without them well they can't keep you
safe forever no one is safe forever
you take care of yourself I mean that
here
[Music]
versatility is not overrated keep it she
needs it more than we do
uh yeah I gotta go she's gonna be on her
own
I thought we were gonna be stranded up
there because it's Aires or whatever but
I guess not
they always end with a hook I'm
surprised I'm so curious what's gonna
happen you'd be asleep by now
okay bet you are you stayed I'm skating
I'm fine okay good hell of a night
though temperatures dropping we're low
on food I think we got to stay put for a
while you know for Rebecca and the baby
so I'm thinking as soon as it gets light
Jane and I should go explore see if we
could find someplace to scavenge what
Jane left for good what what just now
are you serious
she didn't say anything about leaving to
me what [ __ ] come on Tammy
hey keep it down sorry James don't
really Luke of all the childish [ __ ]
outage die-off no this baby's life so
you two can roll around like [ __ ]
teenagers sir I made a mistake no it's
not alright what do you want from me you
guys are both acting like jerks guys do
is fight look I'm sorry okay I [ __ ] up
but you know what Jane she made an offer
and Jesus Christ I needed it okay I mean
look around you okay everything is [ __ ]
so forgive me for one day enjoy one
moment of something else fine but this
baby
he's what matters now got it so get your
[ __ ] together
where's my baby is everything all right
yeah everything is fine if you think you
thin I'm gonna need a good place to race
him which ain't here
we got a push on we head north get to
Wellington that's our best shot
there's a town across the river it might
be safe there
nothing since did might be a good stop
on the way Kenny
I'm sorry
clams got a point that could be a whole
town full of supplies and not that far
from here a whole lot better than here
anyway looks like that's our best bet we
need to get on the road as soon as
possible we leave at first lot oh whoa
what are you talking about Rebecca needs
rest a few days at the least we've got
that baby formula and won't help the
rest of us and what about shelter we'll
freeze out here Luke's right she needs
to rest
we should wait a few days maybe that's
for the best
we don't want to push Rebecca too hard
just give me a day or two Kenny I'll be
fine this is a mistake look we should
all try to get some sleep it's been a
long day it's snowing damn he must be
really cold
sorry okay back it's gonna be alright
she doesn't look she's kind of making
pretty [ __ ] up situation there we go
we're back I took a little nap
I see how this ends
it looks gorgeous look at that yes it
really got cold fast didn't it
she's gonna die for shizzle she's
exhausted we all keep going
we should have left right away instead
of waiting around we could have found
more food and been someplace warm days
ago we did the right thing she was in no
condition to move she's worse now we
could still turn back that's not an
option
everybody hang in there we got to keep
moving if we're gonna make it to that
town before nightfall you don't even
listen to anyone else you just go on
barking orders you gotta lighten up okay
you're pushing them too hard I'm just
doing what has to be done like always
Luke's right everyone's tired why are
you taking his side again we shouldn't
even be out here we could have got to
better shelter days ago I'm not taking
anyone's [ __ ] inside someone take
that baby away from her
Rebecca let me take the baby oh he's
okay
I've got him no you rest for a minute
I'll wash back off Kenny she said she
doesn't want you to take the baby don't
be weird about it okay you're being
weird about it
weird yeah you kind of have been Kenny
knows what he's doing he's been a dad
before that's not the part I was
concerned about well what is this
is that the same guy as before our huh
Jane and I met him on the observation
deck before everyone else can know this
what's he want he doesn't look like much
Eddie the point hello please he has a
sick sister they might be in trouble
all right well we are the ones in
trouble let's get real here how does it
survive with that leg in a zombie
apocalypse and everyone else is doing
[ __ ] hello your name is Clementine yes
these are your friends I'm hoping you
can help me now not like before all of
you can help let's see how he reacts
sister I need
thanks for bandages I need bandages are
you hurt no Nick Akio Russia he could
kill you she's not sick she is the with
the bear I'm sure Sony email you justify
yourself gudiya's now stop or we can
able motion pretty weak you don't want
any trouble
I told them you are the ones who love me
they think it's funny that you're just a
little girl robbed and they want you and
your friends to prevent the gun so we
can take your things whoa whoa hang on
it wasn't me yeah what the [ __ ] it was
Jane it wasn't any of us G where's the
other woman
stop reported aboard Voyager shorten
miss I do not see a woman who was with
you she's gone
she left the group it's academic I know
it and you pledged it sir yes nice
really okay
oh good job yeah that'll do it all of
you just put your guns down
this will be fine we have a baby baby
with you when you couldn't discovery
Beulah nice dance don't do anything
stupid catch what she died oh my god oh
my god oh my [ __ ] god
[Music]
oh [ __ ] me
come on huh whoa there are some tide
choices in this one I've never seen this
before oh my god I'm in the taxi I'm in
the top percentage of all of these so
don't think I don't make good all right
left Sarah at the trailer park we left
Sarah at the trailer park
well I didn't mean to do that
she cuz I didn't [ __ ] see her
compassion did we rob arvo yeah we
refused to steal from our mo you should
be [ __ ] happy crawl through the
ticket booth
yeah because her [ __ ] Clementine
that's what we do
held the baby shot Rebecca did not shoot
Rebecca I don't know how the clay mold
really kill Kenza girl at and I don't
know
holy [ __ ] all right in that was another
episode of the wakened in season two
lives game is awesome that was probably
the best episode so far I felt like it
was more consistent it really reminded
me of the first episode season cold call
me a call me impatient but I just feel
like there's sometimes this is a lot of
talking and a lot of character and then
a lot of not leading up to anything but
everything here felt important to me
when I was playing
which is what it's supposed to be like
right so I really enjoyed this one for
that and it was always interesting and
fun it's all the stuff happening any
night and when it was it was chela when
it was supposed to be chill that it was
intense when I supposed to be intense so
I like that I like that a lot I never
got bored playing in um and yeah it was
long - right it was like 1 hour and 40
minutes so that yeah great episode
usually also think that the episode
before the end is just gonna be like a
lead-up for the end but it I'm happy
with it super excited for the last one I
got damn it every sticker displayed
right away but hey what are you gonna do
but anyway thank you for leaving like on
this video and leaving a comment I
appreciate it and thank you for
supporting this series it means a lot to
me bros sighs the brofist for you
brofist